all right the newest NBC News poll has
voters giving Republicans a 21 Point
advantage on the question of which party
is better at handling the economy and of
course the economy Remains the top
concern in every poll out there for the
American people
so do any of you really think that Biden
has any clue as to how much political
trouble he's in right now
or that anyone is really telling him
inside the White House how bad things
are across the country
folks
presumptuous to say but it's true our
economic vision is working creating jobs
building well providing communities with
a sense of dignity
oh yeah that's all happening but for
most of us we can't unsee or unfeel the
truth
and the truth is on most of the big
issues Democrats under Biden have gotten
their way pretty much everything they've
wanted on the economy the energy sector
the Border schools Urban policy it's all
the way they want it all of it
and under Democrat control all that was
happening well America is in a death
spiral
in Chicago a violent attack and the
mugging of a man just minding his
business in an alleyway
in New York a couple was robbed by a
dozen teens
and in La a 13 year old is assaulted by
a grown woman
according to Cassidy and her mom Cassidy
was with a couple of classmates when she
stopped off at a McDonald's in Harbor
City on her walk home from school
September 6th
but before she could get home safely an
unidentified woman cornered her in the
fast food restaurant and began attacking
her Cassidy says the attack was
unprovoked
these are senseless acts of depraved
hideous violence it's enraging and it
also breaks your heart at the same time
these Brazen criminals are beating their
victims senseless almost for fun
no fear of the justice system not at all
why
because in democrat-run States the
justice system mainly exists to handcuff
the police and also make progressives
feel better about themselves
we're going to promote Public Safety and
respect through the evolution of
neighborhood policing
and on the federal level we all know the
justice system exists mainly to get
Biden reelected that's why the cartels
they're not afraid of the FBI and the
Smugglers aren't afraid of Customs and
Border Protection as well
and the run of the mill thugs ow come on
they're not afraid of police again there
are zero consequences
but the real world consequences of
democrat policies they're piling up
the loss by retailers from theft last
year alone reached 112 billion dollars
and by the way it's just not the the
luxury Outlets like Louis Vuitton it's
department stores and smaller outlets
and of course the bigger stores
Nordstrom's Macy's and Apple
of course the left calls this consumer
reparations yeah
or describes the theft says a desperate
Cry for Help from the oppressed and
marginalized that's one of my favorites
but in fact businesses deserve they
think to lose money because let's face
it they're probably racist anyway so
goes the left-wing argument
but in the real world businesses are not
in the business to lose money but to
make it and now Target is announcing
that it's closing nine stores in major
American cities
now this broke just a day or so before
CVS announced it was closing stores as
well a lot of them 900 by the end of
2024. now though the pharmacy chain
cited increases in online shopping as
the major factor I don't believe that
crime has got to be a major factor as
well again they're not in the business
of losing money
and hard-working Americans they don't
expect to go backwards either
but that's how most of us feel after
living in the Biden economy
the White House treated the failure of
bidenomics remember a couple months ago
as a PR problem they just needed to sell
it differently
but we know it's not about the messaging
it's about the policies that make things
worse in every way
if you want to know by the way where gas
prices are really headed check out
what's happening at the pump in
California
it's too much
not much I can do about it frustrating
yeah
a little higher than I want that's for
sure now every day it seems that the
Biden Administration is taking more
Federal lands as well off the books for
drilling and exploration we know what
that's going to do the price of oil and
gas but now under oil by the way is
predicted to be headed to a hundred and
fifty dollars a barrel
high energy costs we know this isn't one
of the biggest drains on the family
budget it's Incorporated in everything
we buy everything that travels
and this contributes to the fact that
real median household incomes are down
as well at this point now think about
this for a minute it's almost a
certainty that next year when Americans
vote their real median household income
will be lower than it was in 2019.
that's by nomics
but don't worry Intrepid Democrats the
country may be in a flat spin but
Biden's handlers believe that they know
how to keep his prospects for
re-election strong
sneakers yes
axios is reporting that staff is
extremely concerned that Biden could
fall on his face again given his past
tumbles let's face it making sure he
doesn't trip is what they're calling
their critical project forget the Border
forget getting the economy going
but how to keep the chief executive
chiefly upright well they have him
working with a physical therapist isn't
that nice to work on his balance which
has been I guess going on for about two
years and my favorite part he's wearing
sneakers to prevent him from slipping
but operation tennis shoes may not be
working so well because Biden ran a
mission in Michigan today to meet with a
striking UAW workers before Trump
arrives there tomorrow
but instead of stealing Trump's Thunder
Biden almost fell again while exiting
Air Force One even when he went on those
shorter stairs
but of course Biden's fragile state the
country's Dire Straits
it doesn't matter to the plutocrats in
the Bay Area who are pwning up big time
later this week and a pair of
fundraisers for Biden
now
why do you think the Uber Rich from a
dying City want to keep Biden in office
I'll tell you why because they want to
see wages what go up for working people
of course not because they like his
policies that's why Limitless illegal
immigration bringing an endless pool of
cheap workers to the United States and
of course more job Outsourcing to Asia
playing nice with their Pals in China
that's why they're supporting Joe Biden
but for the rest of us
four more years of Joe means four more
years that crime is going to increase of
course more jobs are going to be shipped
overseas
millions of more illegals declining
academic skills
war in Ukraine that's going to continue
gas prices continuing to climb fewer
Americans owning cars inflation is going
to stay high no end in sight for high
interest rates of course a China bailout
you know that's coming
that's going to be the new normal my
friends
now three years ago
there was a possibility it was remote
mode but it was there that Biden would
Embrace this role as a caretaker to help
Americans get back to normal and to
restart the economy post-pandemic
and I think millions of Americans
actually believed that that's what Joe
Biden would do but now we all know the
truth
you can feel it the country is teetering
on the edge we're on life support
but Biden's big donors
and those who actually write what's on
his little note cards that he brings
into the oval well their primary goal is
to permanently and radically change
America and they're on their way
and he's their best tool for
accomplishing that
but fortunately
just over 13 months the voters who've
seen this Carnage up close and personal
we'll have the chance to you know turn
this death spiral around and turn us
back toward the life of freedom and the
greater Prosperity that we all love
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else